okay so the time of this interview is
we're in 2017 is it better for a
screenwriter to focus on spec
screenplays or a spec television pilot
so I think that TV writing and feature
film writing are different art forms
there's a lot of overlap but they're
very different so I think that someone
has to first of all say do I want to be
a feature film writer or don't want to
be a TV writer now it's possibly
possible they want to do both but
generally writers have a preference of
one or the other now that said there is
so much more opportunity and money in TV
than there is in features features are
getting better but not as good although
I know a lot of TV writers who are
sneaking over to the future'
neighborhood because it was a lot less
competition but that said I do have
clients and students who want to be
feature film writers but want to become
TV writers as their day jobs while they
keep writing their moonlight or their
Manchester by the sea or whatever
they're writing but what I would say is
you know there's this training of all
the creative integration and skill sets
and then when you really get to that the
the last train of really designing and
executing on your stories and your
characters it's there's different
training for TV or feature so I would
say if someone is sort of new to this
whole game I pick one of those forms and
really get strong at that before you try
it learning the other I wouldn't be
bouncing back and forth because then you
kind of become kind of good but not
created either now if someone's really
great at one form yeah focus on the
other so it is really hard to sell a
feature film original script but it's
getting a little bit easier which means
it's gone from impossible to almost
impossible both of it it I mean I have
in the last two months I've had four
four students sell feature scrubs and so
it is certainly possible but you see
more action on the the TV side but I
think the mistake that a lot of people
make is they want to go ready TV script
cuz they think that it's there's more
action and it's easier but their heart's
not really into it they don't really
want to be a TV writer don't really
train to be a TV writer and their waste
in their time so I maybe I'm a romantic
but I just think that there's gonna be
so much training and so much dedication
and sacrifice to get into this business
and and what people don't understand is
that getting in the business as hard as
that is there's a lot easier than
staying in the business and if you're
gonna go through all of that then do it
for a career that you want do it for a
life that you want
I mean TV writing and future film
writing is very different I was a
feature phone writer for 11 years I had
total control of my schedule I would
take meetings maybe one or two maybe one
or two days a week but only when I
wanted to most the time I I could be in
Europe writing I could be here writing I
could do what I had so much control over
my schedule I would work really intently
on something for three or four months
and I could take two months off TV
writing is very different you're gonna
be working maybe eight nine months
intensely and then you get time off
you're gonna be working in a room a lot
with other people
some people love that some people hate
that there's a lot more politics that
can go in the TV writing some people can
thrive in that some people hate that now
its feature film writer I would
constantly be writing scripts pouring
heart and soul into something ever got
made my friends a friend it was a writer
on Mad Men and she would write something
and then you know a few months later we
could watch it and I was so jealous of
that she was so jealous that I did my
work literally in Paris for two months
at one time she was very jealous of that
so I would say like think about your
life I think what I always tell writers
is if I couldn't guarantee you success
writing for movies or TV which would you
pick and whichever one you pick if I
could guarantee you success writing any
kind of thing you know any kind of TV
show comedy drama or a movie what would
you pick and then work backwards from
there to see what kind of spec scripts
you should be writing and so have a
vision for what kind of career you want
what kind of life you want work
backwards and write those kinds of
scripts and that's plan a and hopefully
plan a work
now over enough period of time the PNA
is not working you can consider Plan B
Plan B is would be the easier script to
sell where where's the market plate how
do I game the marketplace that doesn't
set you up for the life you want or the
career you want that's just I want an
agent I want to sell us something the
mistake that I made that I hope others
don't make is Plan B was my plan a I was
in film school and I said eh
I heard the story how Jim Carrey and
I'll know this is true or not I was a
struggling comic and he said someone
told him to do this he wrote a check to
himself for 1 million dollars and he
post-dated it a year later and he said
in one year I'm gonna be able to cash
this cheque and within one year he got
living color and he made millions of
dollars is that a true story I don't
know I hope so I don't know but I was 23
years old when I heard it so I thought
it was a true story so I didn't write my
I was I started by a check but it was I
just couldn't do that but I did write in
my calendar one year later I will have
an agent and I will have sold the scribe
I wrote that in that account I told
everyone a year from now I'm gonna do
that
so my when we were walking we move in
the direction of where we're looking
that's our intent
so that was my intent in one year I'll
have an agent in celle scope and it was
actually 13 months later so I didn't
quite make it I had an agent
I actually didn't sell a script but I
sold a pitch to Ridley Scott and he flew
me to London and was on the front page
of variety so I was willing to call that
a success
okay and what I realized as after I
finished metropolis and was on the front
page of variety Ridley was gonna make it
and he said very positive things about
the script and me I was named on the
front page of riot II made my mom's day
and something I was the hot writer in
town and I was getting all these job
offers and I remember thinking all these
offers that I'm getting are four kinds
of things I don't really want to be
writing so I called my agent I'm like I
don't want to be writing those kind of
things I'm so stupid I'm like I'll be
writing these kind of things so get me
those kind of offers and I forget what
she said she said it's such a polite
classy smart woman but she basically
said you idiot if you wanted to be doing
this why did you write this script in
Metropolis
everything you wrote lines you up for
this career
if you don't want this career and you
want that career why did you write those
scripts why did you sell metropolis and
the honest answer is because I was just
trying to get an agent and sell
something I haven't thought I was 24
years old I didn't I was so fixed
mindset I said if I can't sell a script
in a year I'm going to law school
because if I don't solve script in a
year means I don't have what it takes
which is very fixed mindset and very
stupid and so I tell people don't make
the mistake I made
Plan B is okay I just want to get an
agent I just want to sell something I
just want to validate I can do this the
plan a is what career do I want what
life do I want and reverse engineer but
you should be writing to give yourself
of that
you